want to see what happens when mental
illness combines with cult membership
combines with too much time on people's
hands well it's Carrie Lake supporters
Kerry lake is very rapidly heading
towards what is likely but not yet
guaranteed to be a loss in the Arizona
gubernatorial election this is very good
for the residents of Arizona Kerry lake
is one of the worst people to run in
this cycle
right up there with mastriano and Blake
Masters and Herschel Walker and a few
others it is of course a situation that
Kerry Lake and her supporters have
backed themselves into a corner around
because they were insisting
it's rigged there will be fraud and
there if if there is not fraud I will
win I will win I will win and even as
recently as I think it was yesterday
Carrie Lake was saying I'm going to win
it doesn't really look like Kerry lake
is going to win and so her supporters
showed up in Maricopa County and at
other ballot counting centers and they
are mixing religion with mental illness
with cult membership with having too
much time on their hands here is one
clip in which they are demanding that
the military step in and just do a new
election I guess this election was fake
they want a real election by which they
mean one in which Carrie Lake wins all
right we'll be done on Earth as it is in
heaven give us this day
I want all of you to say a prayer right
now we the people are requesting
military step in and redo our election
requests denied sir
[Music]
balls it's full our government is full
of corrupt people
yeah there were a bunch of these people
out here's one person with a megaphone
who was shouting common Shadow
government tropes where uh wealthy men
often they just happen to be Jewish men
are actually in control
moving
that's right
Rockefeller Rothschild and JP Morgan
yep
um then there is another Kerry Lake
supporter calling for a new election and
remember
that they are serious folks the U.S is
now seen as the joke where when your
candidate loses you say we need a new
election and Trump even called for it he
actually called for a new electron not a
new election we'll get to that a little
bit later I I believe at this point we
need to just have a new election at this
point now that it's pretty damn clear
Kerry lake is going to lose now we are
actually ready to say we need a totally
new election and we need to do paper
ballots and we need to do it all in one
day and be done with it we can't expect
it's an absurd notion to sit here and
play this charade and act like after
this counting that we won't have tainted
results either way what he means is it's
hard to believe Carrie Lake will win
after the election is over so we should
just really redo this entire election
yep do it all over again and then
certainly an idea that Trump likes and
then another another point they were
chanting count the legal votes this is
another true well yeah sure there's lots
of votes that count but you're counting
illegal votes only count the legal ones
count the legal votes count to Legal
votes count the legal votes
listen you know this routine now it's
the same routine every election it's the
same that it's just that it's if we lost
it was rigged
stolen there were ballot dumps we need a
new election it was all fake fake fake
rig grigged uh they say nothing in the
races that they won they say nothing in
those races Tim Scott's race in South
Carolina have you heard a peep out of
them about that one of course not
uh Brian Kemp in Georgia they're not
saying a word they're not saying
the Herschel Walker oh very much rigged
Brian Kemp Stacy Abrams same ballots
Stacey Abrams lost genuinely Brian Kemp
won genuinely that's really the result
they say oh no no no that one's real
that one's very real the US is a joke
where we win it's fair if we lose it was
rigged according to these very same
people
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikodo makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikota website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your hand and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below